huawei the world's leading manufacturer
of 5g network gear
a u.s campaign seeks to have allies
around the world dump the supplier for
security reasons
europe has become the focal point of
that campaign and in particular
germany in the high-tech city of
shenzhen where huawei is headquartered
5g is already a reality chinese state
television runs footage of transmission
mass under construction
huawei has become the world's largest
network gear supplier
and was planning to supply its kit for
5g networks around the world
but the us has banned its companies from
doing business with huawei
much to the annoyance of officials in
beijing
what the us has done shows clearly that
the market economy and fair competition
principle it claims to champion is
nothing but a fig leaf
this practice violates the rules of
international trade
disrupts global supply chains and will
inevitably damage america's national
interests
and image washington is calling on the
world to make a decision
against china last week u.s secretary of
state mike pompeo toured europe
and called for huawei to be banned from
5g networks because of espionage fears
europe is divided on how to approach
huawei some countries are lining up with
the us
and restricting huawei are not using its
5g technology at all
others are using huawei's 5g gear
and others are still undecided
the eurozone's biggest economy germany
has so far avoided the decision
it feels caught in the middle but the
usa and china are important trading
partners
berlin doesn't want to ruffle anyone's
feathers
and for more on this i'm joined by
isabelle skereka she's a cyber security
and digital policy researcher
at esmt berlin isabel thanks for joining
us
should europe be concerned should europe
be concerned about huawei as a network
supplier what do you think
i think europe should think about
dependencies in the long term and in
that sense yes it should be concerned
about who it chooses to equip
5g networks strategically because those
networks are critical infrastructures
for the next 20 years and will determine
the fate of our future industry
moreover there are european suppliers
who would be available as well
so we might rather be dependent on
european suppliers than chinese ones
and there are also some security risks
about huawei which are not completely
confirmed
but the laws in china allow the chinese
government to take
influence over chinese companies and
security agencies can force it
potentially to cooperate
on espionage or sabotage all right so
some good technical points about using
huawei
as a supplier is that technical
discussion now being dwarfed
by a larger political discussion and
this tug of war between the u.s and
china
yes it's a very political discussion
it's also a geopolitical discussion
china and the us are basically fighting
over
dominance geopolitical dominance in the
world the u.s
initiative is certainly also an
initiative to preserve
its first position in
the global game so to say so europe
now caught in between really needs to
find its own position
geopolitically as well as
industrially and the focus is really
falling on germany
can berlin really afford to sit on the
finch on the fence rather on this issue
for much longer
no berlin can absolutely not afford to
sit on the fence
it has to take a decision it needs to
act together
with its european allies and partners
because
a sole national decision will not have
as much weight
as a european position this is why the
european union has already initiated
a strategic process last year that
germany is part of
and so in that sense germany now
needs to not only make a technical
decision about technical security of
networks
but also position itself within this
larger geopolitical debate
on the basis of its value european
values
all right we'll have to leave it there
for now isabel skierka with esmt berlin
thank you very much for your analysis
thank you